in an interview with time magazine
yesterday grammy nominee tj osborne
who is one half of brothers osborne came
out as gay
he's gotten public support from other
country artists like dierks bentley
casey musgraves and mayor morris and tj
told ellen today that even he is
surprised by the outpouring of support
yeah his brother john osborne also
showed his sport in an instagram video
you know i think country really comes
from a lot of rural roots that are
a lot of kind of christianity and a lot
of kind of old-school way of thinking
and
and i really think that's changed a lot
over the years and i know it's changed a
lot over the years
and you know i'm really kind of um i'm
curious to see how it all plays out with
us going to rural america you know i
feel pretty
confident going to places like l.a and
going to chicago and
playing here in nashville where i live
and um
you know i'm curious to see how it is
and and kind of the more rural counties
and such and and part of me you know you
know i've been
the other thing just to touch on what
you said earlier ellen you know i think
not only is it a weight off of my
shoulders to kind of tell my truth
but i don't think i i expected a wave of
love from
family and friends and i did not expect
it to feel the way it felt
and you know i think it's one thing when
you know you just know and assume people
love you
and it's different when you hear it and
when you hear it with sincerity and
right now i feel so incredibly loved and
it's one of those things where
you know i'm like god i wish that i
could share this love with other people
and to feel this way
and then to have people that i never
even expected to say anything
um reaching out to me people that i feel
like personify masculinity and straight
culture
to the nth degree who are coming out
with with a lot of
pride for me and it really is one of
those things that was really the
the moment to me that made me feel like
wow that was there the whole time
and yeah i think there are some people
out there that
we there's a lot of hurdles clearly with
people that don't
don't like gay people i mean it's just a
thing and
um but in some respects i do feel like
you know
maybe maybe through my insecurities i've
built it up to maybe be a bigger hurdle
than it really was the whole time i'm
very proud of my brother today
he's taken one of the most important
steps of his entire life
and he's doing it in front of the entire
world
he's always had my support no matter
what he will continue to have my support
it's an honor to call him my brother
he's a beautiful
amazing human being so talented so
caring so giving
and it's an honor to have a member of my
family be a part of the lgbtqia
community um proud of the tj
yeah so storm says it's 2021 folks
coming out as gay is not news but
afro replied to him saying like in the
conservative country music world this is
pretty big
news like for an artist on this level
eminence says people should just be who
they want to be
uh nix is uh welcome to the club tj
proud of you
episodes is good for him i'm proud of
him uh marist has never heard of this
person but as long as he's happy it's
all okay but yeah i mean this is
this is big news but brothers osborne is
huge and we don't have
many openly gay country artists at all
yeah i mean i agree in the sense that
you know i think that it's sad that in
2021 people still need to feel
people still feel the need to announce
their sexuality it's just like a direct
reflection of
how much more work we need to do as a
society
i look forward to the day when it's not
needed that we're just
equal and inclusive and we all love one
another and it's not like a thing but
you know i love what he said to time
magazine he said
i want to get to the height of my career
being completely
who i am and he is one of the first
openly
gay artists in country music signed to a
a major record label and i think it's
really important i think it's timely
especially with what's
happening with morgan wallen you know
that kind of reinforced in
a negative stereotype very recently in
country music so
this is cool i really i'm looking for
forward to a changing country music and
i'm hoping that we can just
normalize that we're not all the same we
can all enjoy the same music and still
have
you know the same lifestyle without
having to you know
say that i'm this way sexually i'm i
don't have to announce that i'm black
you know what i mean it's just i'm just
tired of where it is but
yeah let's i'm looking forward to this
change it's inspiring i'm happy that he
did this there's probably so many people
that needed this
yeah and i think that coming off the
heels of you know of morgan
which is that was the debate was
not a representation of country and
other people were saying no
this is the representation of and now to
have tj come out and and you see
the massive outpouring of a support
forum uh is is incredible and i
love these guys i have talked to the
brothers i was born probably more times
than any other artist that i've
interviewed in the past three or you
know two or three years
i i have such a huge place in my heart
for both of them they're so genuine
so wonderful and they love their mom and
they're so kind to each other
and they're very talented and so it
makes me happy
that uh that he was able to to to to to
do this today but i love it it's like
you do you you do instagram you do
people magazine and then you do your
stop at ellen and that's the sort of
thing that you do
you come out and uh and and he hit them
all and
everybody welcomed him with open arms
and uh and i love the guy
yeah it's interesting like i think
country music is really going through a
wrecking the past
couple years like with morgan walling
yesterday and it was great to see the
response
to that we've seen like mickey gaiden
we've seen jimmy allen like they're
finally taking notice of black punch
artists now we have tj osborne
so it's going to be interesting to see
how country music evolves this is
finally the time
the country music is going to evolve and
i think tj has a little bit rose-colored
glasses on right now
i think you know this first day that he
got all the support there are going to
be fans that don't like this he is going
to go to shows
and there's going to be people that are
boycotting like it happened with jojo c
wood
happened with little nasdaq they get hit
up on social media like he is going to
get people that come after him and he's
going to have to deal with it there's
right away that jojo sibo had to deal
with it because right away
little nazak's had to deal with it so he
is going to have to deal with it it's
not going to be
all you know rainbows for uh tj there's
going to be backlash and i find it
interesting too in this circumstance
that him coming out really has an effect
on john his brother too because he's
part of this group
and john's almost pulled along with this
like now he has to be a real
open ally and there's going to be some
backlash that john's going to have to
take
as well but yeah it's a great thing like
i mean yeah it's going to be a great
time where one day we
do get to uh yeah it's not news and
people don't come out we're a long way
from that like i mean especially in
country music
we don't have that representation and
for kids to see oh there's someone like
me in country music or wherever it is
the world
like it's still very important to
acknowledge this i know straight people
don't get that idea sometimes
because they've always been able to walk
down the street and hold the hand of the
person they love and kiss the person
that they love in public but that was
not the case it's because people came
out of the closet
but that's where the lgbtq community is
where it is today and it still has
a ways to go so it's absolutely
important to come out and and be
yourself
yeah and keisha you had mentioned a
reckoning in in country music and and i
don't think that we
can blow past the effect
of little nasdaq's had a few years ago
because
he created something where they had to
look internally like they've never had
to look internally
before because he showed up being as
flamboyant and as awesome as he is
and that they had to determine what was
country
and was he not country because he was
gay was he not country because he was
black
was he not country because he was
rapping over a country beat
like what made him not country when they
came out and dug their heels into the
ground
the rest of the world looked at the
country music and said no
no no no no no no no no no no no no and
i think lil nad's x
point and his sort of marker in the
reckoning
of that entire industry i don't think
that we'll i don't think we're going to
realize how big that actually was for
the reckoning for years to come
i think it was i think it was huge i
think that it played an effect on
morgan wallen and i think that it has an
effect on tj coming out yesterday
and i think that it had a huge effect
that hasn't fully been realized yet
yeah absolutely i agree yeah i can't
wait till we don't have to announce our
differences
we just love one another and everybody
is like we
uh we're all here we just skipped down
i'm not going to start loving everybody
but if i don't if i don't not love you
it's not going to be because you're gay
it's going to be for a vast
amount of other reasons